from somewhere near here they'll head
somewhere out there and this is the
transport the rocket that will carry
satellites from Scotland into space they
call it Prime and it's the latest
example of britain's orbital ambitions
this is the piece that actually goes
into space below this is a much bigger
stage that pushes this into space and
this is the engine that will then propel
it to the final altitude there's a 3d
printed engine and it's controlled by
this computer here which is like an
engine management system on your
standard car but it's special computer
first space and it burns the fuels of a
container with this lightweight
carbon-fiber tank and one of them is
propane which people will know from
their own barbecues it's a LPG and
Yelton but goal is to deliver the things
in the nosecone here which ultimately
open opens up like a Moonraker rocket
that people might have seen in James
Bond movies and inside there are the
satellites which can be as small as a
Rubik cube or as big as a washing
machine Construction has taken place at
a new purpose-built rocket Factory on
the murray coast the plan is to turn the
company graphic into reality by 2021
launching from a planned space port up
the road in Sutherland UK satellites are
already sent into space it's big
business but they have to be launched
from sites abroad and the likes of
Kazakhstan and India involving big
waiting times and big costs catching a
flight closer to home will be more quick
convenient and cost-effective present to
the Rockets PR launch companies who've
already made bookings we obviously need
a lot of launching capabilities and and
flexible and regular launching
capabilities and all Beck's is just a
perfect perfect fit for us the plan is
for six vertical launches a year from
the north of Scotland with a promise of
multi-billion pound economic benefit in
the long run in the highlands the Space
Age is aging well James Matthews Sky
News in forests